with us right now is the former attorney
general United States Jeff Sessions he
is running for his old Senate seat in
Alabama he was kind enough to join us
right now Attorney General senator thank
you for coming thank you need oh it's
great to be really asked you how you
feel
same here sir how do you feel about
requiring versus urging people to wear
masks what would you tell those in
Alabama about that I think whenever
possible people should wear a mask I
would support that for sure if
somebody's out in their yard and not
close to anyone I don't think they have
to wear the mask and I guess it's
someone on an individual decision but
there is no doubt that you do expel
droplets and even the most basic cloth
masks can help make the person less
contagious and less likely to spread the
virus are you optimistic etc that we can
get to a point by the end of this month
we could start easing back some of these
stay at home shelter in place measures
that you know some 41 states including
Alabama have now I absolutely hope that
we can do that it's so important we do
not need to prolong this economic
catastrophe really any longer than we
have to it's the two trillion dollars is
one of the large largest expenditure of
money and in American history all that's
borrowed so we do need to see and take
every smart effort to be as effective
productively for our economy as we
possibly can in prolonged unnecessary
delays or really have great potential
for harm now you are in a runoff with
the former Auburn football coach Tommy
Tuberville for the Republican nomination
for the Senate do you think that summer
runoff election should be delayed well
it has been delayed it was delayed a
good bit now to July 14th
and it is but there ways you can
communicate with the people of Alabama
you can't travel in him rallies and
events like we've done in the past but
social media electronic communications
conference calls television radio talk
shows have been very effective I think
for me and I've done a lot of that so
those are the things that you have to do
we can't just stop what we're doing we
have an important Senate race to be
decided this summer as to who will
represent there are people who have who
have wanted to push that back senator
even beyond July 14 as you know the
Democratic National Convention itself
has been pushed back from mid-july to
mid-august do you think it is wise now
to do what the National Party did the
National Democratic Party no it's
different here that that contest which
has been pushed back at least twice well
I think with regard to Alabama we didn't
really need to get this election done I
think this is one of the latest dates
you can have and actually be able to
carry out a November election in a
proper way so I think that's probably
where we're heading the Secretary of
State has made clear that people can
vote absentee if they are fearful of
their health and I believe that we can
conduct this election and I expect it
will be conducted July 14 um general one
of the things that but you've been doing
a good campaign is attack yourself very
attaching yourself very closely to the
president apparently his campaign
demanded that you stop it and saying
that you are delusional in doing so have
you stopped either referencing and your
mailings or anything having to do with
the president and your attachment to him
well I said I was supporting him that I
was his top most prominent national
supporter the first one done in the
Senate to announce that support I
continue to support his immigration
policies his trade policy I support his
leadership on the virus I think he's
doing a great job as president and no
lawyer from Washington can say that
I can't say I support the president I
will also say there I don't think
there's anybody in Alabama that doesn't
know we had a disagreement I did what I
thought was right and the thought was
responsible and required of me and I
would just say this Watson has been
wrong before I intend to take my case to
the people of Alabama under the
Constitution they decide who their
senator is I believe I'm best qualified
to represent them I have a record of
advancing their values our principles
with integrity and integrity and vigor
and that's why what I'll be doing when I
take my case to the people of Alabama
well as you know sir the president is
supporting coach Tuberville here were
you hurt by that when he announced that
the president's free to make his own
decisions we had a disagreement but I do
believe the people of Alabama understand
me they understand that we like the
president I do our advant we want him to
be successful want him to continue to be
a great great president I'll be a big
supporter of his and we've got to talk
about some big issues like China and how
this happened you know I really do
believe that this is an opportunity for
America particularly what I learned as
Attorney General of the United States
that we need to stand up now to identify
and point out
China's failure to tell the world about
this pandemic one study in England said
95 percent of the infections would not
have occurred had this been reported
three weeks earlier so this is a
colossal disastrous failure and we need
to know that as we deal with China in
all kinds of areas that they don't tell
the truth they're seeking competitive
advantage unfair advantage and if we do
the right thing we bet on America we
stand up to this and I have a plan for
first we need an investigation we need
to investigate how they have covered
this up in the extent of the damage we
need to identify medicines and how we
I'm dependent on China for that and stop
it we've got to make sure women senator
are you saying that the Chinese are you
saying that the Chinese lied because the
president has not gone that far he is
concerned about the China virus as he
called it that it started there but he's
not taken the leap you have that the the
Chinese were deliberately lying or
misleading on these early numbers you
had well they I think he said repeatedly
he has not been happy with what he was
told from China he's tried to maintain a
personal relationship with the leader of
China which I certainly think is
appropriate but what we as a nation need
to do is to help the president be more
effective he's been the first one to
challenge China he's had improvements in
our agricultural exports to China he's
used tariffs he needs to be supported in
that and to continue this over a period
of years and to stand up to the abuse as
Attorney General if you're right senator
if you're right about this but if you're
right about this and many agree with you
sir that the Chinese did kind of snooker
us on this and that maybe they suckered
us on trade and that maybe or the trust
we placed in them to stick to agreements
to stick to anything was misplaced do
you feel that everything the Chinese
have been saying whether it's this now
pandemic or even commitments and
promises they made on trade should be
looked at cautiously yes it's time for
us to reset our relationship we can have
a good relationship with China in the
years to come but it cannot be founded
on lies and deceit and unfair trade
agreements with actions by truck China
we've got to stand out to them if they
don't let us sell in their markets we
need to reduce their ability to sell in
our markets if they steal our
intellectual property we need to
prosecute them we've gone from zero
prosecutions of Chinese entities to
after my time is Attorney General there
now 50 cases with over a
investigations ongoing about illegal
activity from China we've got to end
this and get on a healthy relationship
it would be the best thing for our peace
and prosperity in the future but with
the idea that we act we yes and let them
wiggle off the hook and deny that they
suppress these doctors suppress the
revealing to the world of the dangers of
this pandemic as it was spreading it's
one of the greatest cover-ups in the
history of the world
it is a clap is a colossal disaster and
they have got to be held to account the
world needs to know it they don't need
to get too cheap to 9:00 to 9:00 denying
as they've done in the past and we need
to hold them to account and establish
this it'll be good for the people of
China to see that the leadership the
Communist Party did not get away with it
you know finally sir I know you've been
asked this many many times and there's
now fractious relationship you have with
the President to this day he blames your
recusal for the you know the unwinding
of this investigation that he called a
which on but that he claims it all
started with you and he has never
forgotten or clearly forgiven you for
that do you think he ever will well we
had a disagreement over my decision that
I felt I was obligated to do to recuse
myself otherwise we've had a harmonious
partnership on the great issues of our
time and I would intend to I'll continue
to advance that harmonious relationship
would you have any regrets now you had
to do it all over again would you you
never regret doing what you believe is
the right thing Neil I was convinced I
had to do that I was required to do that
my faith and my commitment to law is
such that I would never fail to do my
duty under those circumstances and I did
what I felt I had to do
all right senator very good having you
we'll see what happens in the contest
and all of this the virus and the China
thing that you're taking to them very
good having you on Jeff Sessions the
former attorney general of these United
States